الثانيه وهي اتفاقات تبرم بين العشائر
لدفع الديات المترتبه على من يرتكب ذنبا
او ما يسمى عشائريا بالمسبب ويدفع المسبب
مبالغ من المال يتم الاتفاق عليها تسمى
الفصل وفي كثير من الاحيان تتعارض قيمه
الفصل مع الشريعه الاسلاميه ومن المصطلحات
العشائريه العطوه وهو عرف عشائري يعني
الوقت الذي يعطيه اهل المقتول الى اهل
القاتل لكي يجتمعون معهم ويحددون الديه
الفصل لكن في حاله مرور هذا الوقت بدون
حصول الفصل يحق لاهل المقتول قتل اي شخص
من اهل القاتل
لا يخفى على الجميع ان الاعراف العشائريه
مثل الفصل وتحديد الفصل وامتثال الفصل الى
فتوى للمرجعيه باخذ الديه الشرعيه واضافه
الى ذلك في زمن القرون القديمه هناك بعض
الظواهر كانت تعطى الفصليه من المراه
للعشيره الاخرى المتنازع معها لاهداف
تحقيق السلم المجتمعي بالصوره الحقيقيه
التي تكون مصاهره مع العشيره المتخالفه
معها حتى يكون انجاب اطفال ويكون من
العشيره المتخاصمه معها انجبوا اطفال من
خلال هذه المراه واصبحوا اقرب ما بينهم
وعدم تكرار الجريمه او القتل او الشجار
بينهم